if the medium is the message and it
doesn't matter what we say on TV why are
we all here tonight and why am I asking
this question there is a huge technology
involved in TV which surrounds you
physically and the effect of that huge
service environment on you presently is
vast the effect of the program is
incidental
the effect of the program is incidental
the effect of the program is incidental
the effect of the program is incidental
Marshall McLuhan's famous saying the
medium is the message poses interesting
questions for the age of online video he
gets to the basic point in that clip new
forms of media actually reorganize a
consciousness in McLuhan z-- time the
great shift in media was from print to
electronic media radio and more
importantly television where the printed
book was what he called hot media and
intense one-way offloading of
high-definition information into your
mind the TV was cool it was low
definition on in a busy house
interrupted by commercials playing to
all the senses in other words it
demanded your participation to fill in
the gaps every kind of media from print
to radio to music to television to the
Internet creates a kind of invisible
environment around us when you're
watching TV you may be aware of the
particulars show of how funny or
engaging it is of how relatable the
characters are but rarely do we perceive
or step back to understand what it
actually means to watch TV what it means
to be in that audio-visual and immersive
sensory environment it's no surprise
that the great triumphs of television is
the triumph of advertising what could
possibly be more attune to the medium of
television than commercials in 30
seconds or a minute they invite or
require participation while triggering
each and every one of the senses this is
not to say that advertisements are good
for us just good for TV just as early
television took its cues from print
radio and film before coming into its
own online video has taken its cues from
TV but like TV online video is a wholly
new medium operating in its own
environment reshaping our consciousness
again I mean just the way we watch is
different we're closed up to the screens
transfixed with the screens are small
often the size of a phone whereas my
hand is rarely on
the remote control it's nearly always on
the mouse inviting different kinds of
agencies like the ease at which you can
scan through something all these things
and I'm sure many more that you could
identify have effects on the styles that
become widely viewed and adopted but I
think the largest ingredient of online
video is the awareness that every
consumer is a potential creator the
appeal of lo-fi of making something that
anyone could potentially produce is
extremely important to the culture of
online video so much so I'm tempted to
say that what's considered flawed and
imperfect videography in the eyes of
other media is actually essential to
online video McLuhan was fond of saying
that radio was more suited to packages
to completed products while TV had a
preoccupation with processes - seeing
how things were done I think this
extends even further with online video
just take a look at daily vlogs
perhaps the form that's most tailored to
the medium of online video the process
of filming your day of how the camera
moves is vital to the concept and there
are certainly a number of other styles
that have been proven to be highly
compatible with online video one that
comes to mind is animated explainer
let's try to make a list of some more in
the comments below I don't completely
agree with McLuhan when he says the
effect of the programme is incidental
but I do think that great valuable
content for online video has to be
matched with a style that fits of the
medium of course it's still really early
in the history of this medium in 10 or
20 years with a better perspective we'll
be able to look back at all this work
and point to the first true masterpieces
of the medium but what's exciting now is
that those of us who are working in
online video are in effect creating the
form we're writing the language of this
new medium and for that reason
experimentation and innovation have to
continue to be a top priority and even
for those who just watch it's essential
to study this medium as it grows to be
aware of its message
and the unique environment it creates
because all aspects of the media have an
irresistible force
when invisible hey guys some exciting
news I have 20 more nerdwriter mugs
available on my patreon page I learned a
lot from the first batch but god they
came out so great so there are five
dollars and in order to make the price
work you'll get them after 5 videos and
I'll be watching that so I do a video a
week now so it shouldn't be too long
I basically break even I just want you
guys to have whoo because I think
they're so cool click here anywhere on
the mug and you can claim them while
they last the first batch went pretty
fast thanks again for watching a new
video will be out next Wednesday and
I'll be in comments to talk about this
because I want to talk about this a lot
more so find me down there and I'll see
you next time